-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all
doing well tonight and now,
if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden today signed
the Respect for Marriage Act
into law.
Respecting marriage?
Wow, he really is
undoing all of Trump's orders.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Los Angeles Mayor Karen Bass
yesterday officially resigned
from the House
of Representatives,
which means she's the only
person in Los Angeles
who doesn't have
at least two gigs.
"Me? I'm a mayor/
congresswoman/waiter."
[ Laughter ]
When asked yesterday
if he would consider
leaving the Democratic Party,
like Arizona
Senator Kyrsten Sinema,
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin told reporters,
"I'll look at all
of these things.
I've always looked
at all those things,
but I have no intention
of doing anything right now."
Well, he sounds
like a Democrat to me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams
spoke today
at the National Mathematics
Improvement Project,
but this is sad --
he used the opportunity
to promote division.
[ Laughter ]
Coming around, you guys.
You know what's happening
right now.
You're doing the math
on that joke
and it's working up.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's adding up.
The New York Times yesterday
released its list
of The 93 Most Stylish 'People'
of 2022.
Don't bother asking,
Portia from "White Lotus."
[ Laughter ]
Sam Bankman-Fried,
the disgraced founder
of cryptocurrency exchange FTX,
was arrested yesterday
in the Bahamas.
Oh, they got him, huh?
I can't believe he wasn't able
to blend in.
[ Laughter ]
Who fingered him, the humidity?
HBO tonight debuted
"Pelosi in the House,"
which is a new documentary
about House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi
and not, as I had assumed,
a sitcom on the CW.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
people who use an alarm clock
to wake up
are more tired than people
who wake up naturally.
Though, people who wake up
naturally tend to be more fired.
[ Laughter ]
A cow in Virginia recently
escaped from a trailer
and crashed through the glass
doors of an office --
Oh, sorry,
I read the punch line first.
What's black and white
and red all over?
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Ohhs ]
Another math joke.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
according to new research,
taking the erectile dysfunction
drug Viagra
can decrease the risk
of developing
Alzheimer's disease,
which is great,
because there's nothing worse
than getting an erection
and forgetting why.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
"Who was here?"
[ Applause ]
-Whoo!
-And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We got a great show
for you tonight.